time makes sense
in small pieces but when you look at
huge
stretches of time it's almost impossible
to wrap your head around things
so let's start small with minutes hours
days you probably spent the last 24
hours
mostly sleeping and working and you
probably wasted a good chunk of
yesterday
on the internet days become weeks
weeks become months and then we have a
year
let's look at 2017 france started to
train eagles to hunt terrorist drones
a czech nuclear power plant held a
bikini contest to pick their new intern
and people on the internet made a
challenge out of eating
bleach you know the usual stuff
let's go back further a kid born in the
first year of the 21st century
is 18 years old now but the century is
still young
even if you're not it was largely shaped
by the attacks on 911
which led to the war in afghanistan and
the invasion of iraq
in march 2011 the syrian civil war began
and is still ongoing after seven years
most of us were born in the 20th century
which had the two most devastating wars
in human history
and the cold war for the first time ever
we could destroy ourselves with nuclear
weapons
and we almost did but we also had a
space race
and left earth for the first time the
internet was also invented
which led to memes but also to facebook
and twitter
so all in all we're not sure if this was
a good development
the average human lives about 79 years
which covers a good chunk of recent
history
the oldest living person on earth is
currently seleno haramito
who was born in 1896 which means that
his birth was closer to napoleon ruling
europe
than to the current day only 250 years
ago
the industrial revolution turned the
world into a progress machine
farmers became workers and knowledge
became easier to distribute
around this time we started the progress
that is causing climate change today
not that long ago actually the theory of
evolution
changed how we saw ourselves and the
world we live in
newton wrote down his theory of gravity
we discovered
distant stars and very close bacteria
the 15th century was very eventful
columbus's
discovery of america and the fall of
constantinople
marked the end of the middle ages war
was all the rage in the middle ages
but the number one killer was disease
the black plague
killed every third european in just six
years
around 2000 years ago we set the
arbitrary year one of our calendar
that most of the world follows today but
to a roman
the world was already ancient the great
pyramids were constructed 4500 years ago
so to a roman the pyramids were older
than the romans are to us today
so long ago that there were still living
mammoths on earth
a lot of history happened before that
even around 7 000 years ago
humans began writing things down about
12 000 years ago
human organization exploded we built our
first temple
and around the world mankind began
farming which enabled the rise of larger
communities
our dominance over planet earth really
begins here
homo sapiens sapiens the modern human
evolved at least 200 000 years ago
50 000 years ago the cognitive
revolution expanded our minds and
innovation back then we shared earth
with at least five other human species
that either died out or were killed by
us
at least two million years ago our
ancestors already had control over fire
and constructed tools from wooden stone
and six million years ago the last
common ancestors of chimpanzees and
humans existed
so this graph is all of human history
our close relative homo erectus survived
10 times longer than we have existed
this tiny part is the human error
we have to zoom in a lot to even see
your lifetime
still all of human history is not that
long
65 million years ago the age of the
dinosaurs ended
in an enormous explosion the dinosaurs
ruled the earth
for over 165 million years
27 times as long as all humans
that's so long that it means a t-rex
that lived
65 million years ago is closer to us
today
than to a live stegosaurus
dinosaurs in the form of mighty chickens
are still around today
animal life on this planet started 600
million years ago
the earliest animals were fish and other
small simple sea creatures
then came insects then reptiles and
finally
around 200 million years ago mammals
joined the party
life itself began much further back
there is evidence that it appeared
up to 4.1 billion years ago
for at least 3.5 billion years life
consisted only of single-celled
organisms
4.5 billion years ago the sun was born
from a gigantic imploding gas cloud
60 million years later earth formed
in those early years frequent
bombardment by comets and asteroids
supplied the earth with large oceans
but as far as the whole universe goes
our solar system is pretty new
13.75 billion years ago the universe was
born
and about half a billion years later our
own galaxy formed from billions of stars
but what came before the big bang the
truth is
we don't know and maybe we never will
and there you have it the past
now let's take a look at what we know
about the future in roughly 1 billion
years
the sun will be so hot that life on
earth becomes impossible
the death of the sun 4 billion years
later marks the end of life in the solar
system
if we want to have a chance to survive
we need to have ventured to the stars
and what happens after that in the next
100 billion years
most of the bigger stars around will die
the universe becomes dimmer and dimmer
illuminated only by smaller red and
white dwarfs
but they too will eventually burn out
and one day
the last star in the universe will die
the universe will turn dark and at some
point
even black holes will evaporate and die
when they do
our universe will reach its final stage
heat death
nothing changes anymore the universe is
dead
forever now you're feeling some pretty
weird feelings right now aren't you
we are too it's only natural the good
news is
this is all far far away
the only time that actually matters is
now
that cute girl or boy you like ask them
out
time is precious make it count
one of the questions we get asked the
most is how we make animated videos
the short answer is with adobe after
effects and years of training
but if you'd like to get a glimpse we
now have something for you
we made skillshare tutorials explaining
in detail how we animate scenes from our
videos
if you aren't already familiar with it
skillshare is an online learning
community with more than eighteen
thousand classes in things like writing
animation and video editing their
premium membership gives you unlimited
access to high quality classes from
professionals working in their fields
so you can improve your skills unlock
new opportunities
and do work that you really enjoy it's
also extremely affordable
the annual subscription is less than ten
dollars a month
the first 1000 people to sign up get
their first two months for only 99 cents
so if you want to learn new things and
support kurtz kazakhs
give it a try how did you like this
remake
we're thinking about redoing a few of
our older videos in the next one or two
years
any videos you would like to see redone
you